Florida in the eye of the storm as
hurricane Ian touches down welcome
everyone to Entertainment Tonight Kev
this has potential to be catastrophic
yeah it does Michelle you know these
storms are so deadly and you might not
realize how dangerous they are for the
journalists who have to cover them
joining us now from Tampa David begno
he's the lead National correspondent for
CBS News and David right off the bat I
want to ask you during these storms we
always see these amazing shots of
reporters in the rain and the wind how
do you get those shots yet stay safe
first thing we do is we look for a hotel
maybe a house where we can hunker down
yet get out quickly second we bring
things like a helmet I've had a crew
tile a rope around my waist to keep me
safe from from flying away at one
particular storm I don't use the word
monster often but the monster with the
winds increasing now they are shutting
down the causeway bridge
for the importers from all the networks
Brave the hurricane force winds The
Weather Channel's Mike Seidel struggling
to stand today as he covered Ian
the wind and the eye walls heading in
here we're going to keep an eye on this
David can you give us a behind the
scenes look at what's going on around
you yeah I'll take you in our hurricane
control center we got the teleprompter
so I could toss to the crews in the
field this morning as I field anchored
CBS mornings we have the team here Nora
O'Donnell there sitting in the middle
and her producers monitoring what's
happening with the local news reports
the national feeds this room is sort of
a war room if you will you got food got
a place to rest but this is where we
hunker down this is where we do the
writing the planning all before we go on
air also impacted by Ian Disney World
and Universal Orlando both shut down
ahead of the storm's approach
several celebs have homes near the
storm's path including Tom Cruise John
Cena John Travolta Kirsty alley and of
course Tom Brady amid reports that the
quarterback and Gisele Bundchen are
having troubles in their marriage the
hurricane seems to have forced an end to
their physical separation it's a scary
thing when it really hits your doorstep
Thomas left Tampa Bay and is in Miami
now where the Buccaneers are holding
practice he is reportedly reunited with
Gisele at their home there everyone will
be in our thoughts and prayers as we go
through it hopefully we can come back
later in the week and play against the
chief Sunday night I don't think that
anyone's really prepared for this
[Music]